[Música]
porque el senado de brasil vota hoy el
informe que acusa al presidente de ese
país de aire bolsonaro por su gestión de
la pandemia tras más de seis meses de
investigación la comisión de
investigación parlamentaria pidió
procesar al mandatario de nueve delitos
entre ellos el del crimen contra la
humanidad por sus decisiones y omisiones
frente a esta crisis sanitaria que dejó
más de 600 3.000 muertos en ese país el
documento también señala otras 68
personas entre ellas tres hijos del
mandatario tres ministros y cuatro ex
ministros además de empresas y
ejecutivos que habrían participado
mediante famous y también de manera
negacionista y anti vacuna el apoyo al
presidente para ello quiero saludar
entonces en este momento a patricia rey
de la socióloga investigadora y también
política gracias a investigar a política
perdón mejor dicho gracias patricia por
estar con nosotros en directo américa
aquí en france 24 qué pasará entonces
con el futuro del presidente posicionar
empezamos por esa pregunta que es la del
millón que todo el mundo pues no sabe
qué pasa y cuáles podrían ser como los
escenarios que podría haber al sonar
patricia
y bueno tiene una situación complicada
lo primero que se puede decir es que en
brasil las instituciones democráticas
están funcionando y no es que el
presidente puede hacer lo que quiera
ahora se termina el informe que va a
pasar por una votación en el senado y
después esto es
pasado a la procuraduría general de la
unión para ver si presenta denuncia
tienen mucho apoyo en el senado para
aprobar el informe con lo cual va a ser
muy difícil que el procurador general lo
archive entonces esto es un proceso que
va a venir largo
porque tiene implicaciones jurídicas y
tiene implicaciones que son las más
rápidas políticas y sociales entre sus
para la próxima elección ahora patricia
usted como sociólogo cómo es el
comportamiento de la población respecto
a las decisiones de sus líderes al al
discurso de sus líderes realmente el
presidente o al sónar podría tener
alguna responsabilidad si se quiere para
no meternos en el ámbito de la justicia
moral en esta pandemia con 19 patricio
sí sí fíjate que el perdió mucho de su
apoyo entre la población hoy por hoy
tiene el 23 por ciento de personas que
tienen la intención de votarlo en las
próximas elecciones y esto es un número
que viene cayendo se mantiene estable
pero en muy bajo nivel lula que fue el
presidente que la gente lo que hizo
votar
afuera hoy tiene el 48% de las
intenciones de voto y una de las cosas
cuando uno hace las investigaciones no
solamente estadísticas pero se va a la
parte cualitativa es que la gente se
impresionó con la falta de empatía del
presidente con todo lo con las cosas que
dijo con su manera de
no prestar atención y no tener un gesto
de contención hacia la gente que estaba
sufriendo tenemos 600 3.000 muertos es
un número muy muy grande muy
impresionante entonces su falta de
empatía más que nada fue lo que les
desencanto no los desilusionó así que no
tiene unas situaciones más complicadas
socialmente ahora patricio también está
la manzana de la discordia no la
economía y la salud porque ciertamente
esta pandemia
a todos nos cogió por sorpresa pues no a
nosotros y evidentemente a nuestros
mandatarios a todos los líderes
mundiales que nos hayan en principio que
hacer
pues economía y salud evidentemente la
salud debería ser primero pero que
entonces pasó en el caso de brasil donde
el gobierno primo digamos un poco más la
economía que la salud además más allá de
eso es estimar una pandemia que todavía
sigue siendo un poco desconocida con los
efectos que puede tener en nuestra salud
sí bueno igual haber priorizado la
economía no nos ahorro de absolutamente
ningún desastre económico si estamos
viviendo inflación suba de precios el
precio de la nafta está carísimo y esto
tiene un impacto en la vida cotidiana de
la gente el precio del gas así que
económicamente también estamos muy muy
complicados y las ayudas del gobierno no
alcanzan para traer un poco de alivio a
la gente que más lo necesita
entonces es como que priorizamos la
economía pero esto tampoco nos ayuda y
el tema de la salud los números ahí
están si digamos o sea que al final
primar la economía no sirvió porque pues
la economía ya igual en brasil está
realmente afectada patricia también aquí
el informe dice el presidente tiene
responsabilidad de
infracción de medidas sanitarias
preventivas empleo irregular de fondos
públicos incitación a delitos
falsificación de documentos privados
tiene el crimen contra la humanidad
delito de responsabilidad todo esto
usted dice que si tiene la posibilidad
de que realmente el senado vote a favor
de en efecto juzgar al presidente
devolución ar pero que tan real pueden
ser esas medidas en contra del
mandatario
serán lentas porque el congreso no puede
hacer nada en este momento entonces esto
tiene como que un protocolo que es muy
largo entonces ahora
y el el senado la prueba esto va a la
procuraduría la procuraduría va a volver
a examinar el material todo lo que tiene
para ver si abre denuncia puede ser que
no habrá denuncia porque tiene el poder
decir acá no lo vamos a mover y esto
está no tiene suficientes pruebas no
entonces lo puede archivar y ahí vamos a
tener otro proceso público pero contra
en contra de bolsonaro están también las
acciones de impeachment por otras
cuestiones que ya así que tiene un par
de procesos que están ahí en la
procuraduría que el procurador los
starch y perdón y te como tuvo muchas
medias mediatización digamos me parece
que va a ser un poco difícil que lo
archivó
por completo pero después se pueden
fragmentar las denuncias porque no es
solamente bolsonaro que está son
más de 68.000
de 68 personas que están en este proceso
entonces ahí vamos a ver cuáles son los
caminos de la justicia pero es un camino
lento un camino lento y vamos a ver si
finalmente le llega entonces justamente
estábamos viendo anteriormente esas
imágenes en vivo no de este comité
investigador del senado que está
discutiendo para ver si finalmente pues
se inicia este proceso judicial contra
el presidente evolucionar o solo como
usted lo decía en este momento por la
pandemia de colitis y me porque ya tiene
otros procesos abiertos y exacto por
esto el costo ahora bolsonaro es mucho
más político porque demuestra que su
apoyo en el congreso no es grande y
también el apoyo en la población también
ha disminuido un montón lo que pasa es
que sus 23 por ciento de intenciones
ciertos es de una minoría que es muy
estridente y que sabe gritar mucho así
que tienen tienen su poder